watch your mic
[Music]
there's something that wasn't a
situation where like you know setting up
in this doing it at a time where a lot
of people were running the other
direction the negative is and its
current in every seventh example United
States
[Music]
[Music]
we had an amazing day as you know we
left Ohio and the love the respect for
the office of the presidency it was I
wish you could have been in there to see
it
I wish you could have been in there and
it was no different here we went to the
hospital just came from the hospital we
were there a lot longer than we were
anticipated to be it was supposed to be
just a fairly quick we met with numerous
people we met with also the doctors the
nurses the medical staff they have done
an incredible job both places just
incredible and the the enthusiasm the
love the respect and also the telling me
the let's see if we can get something
done and Republicans want to do it and
Democrats want to do it and by the way
here is a great hero
this man the job he did you all know who
it is everybody but what a job
what a job we did there are a lot of
heroes there are a lot of heroes people
with just incredible work now we're
going in that belief and say hello to
some of your thoughts the 54 of the most
respected men in law enforcement and
[Music]
[Music]
various members of the media when they
should acknowledge that you know that
yeah they shouldn't be thought of to
keep divinity I had it with sherrod
Brown he and the mayor man Wally they
asked to go in because we possibly go in
and make the drill at you I said yeah
let's do it
they couldn't believe what they saw and
they said to people we they've never
seen anything like it
the entire Hospital no different than
what we had in El Paso the entire
Hospital was I mean everybody was so
proud of the job they did because they
did a great job they did a great job and
then I say goodbye I took them in at
their request we made it through they
couldn't believe it she said the people
he said it to people I get her an Air
Force one where they do have a lot of
televisions I turned on the television
and then they are saying well I don't
know it was appropriate for the
president you know acceptor in separate
you know the same old line and they're
very dishonest people and that's
probably why he got I think about 0%
that he failed as a presidential
candidate we're gonna go in and see some
very great people and I wanted to meet
this hero before I did anything and we
all right this way guys a cutlass
darkness